everybody is Charlie we got all kinds of
flash stuff to talk about and crossover
turns out Barry is still the fastest man
alive but now Stephen Amell is playing
Barry during the crossover so we'll do
top 10 WTF then I'll talk about the
crossover stuff because this picture
just sells it so well this is gonna be
so much fun
careful for spoilers from episode 2 if
you haven't seen it yet there's a new
round of that flash ring giveaway - all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a flash related
comment on the video starting with
number 10 they pick up immediately in
that cicada fight at the end of last
week's episode showing you exactly what
his abilities are how strong he is he's
already a big dude Chris Klein actually
looked pretty jacked Cisco made another
really awesome for reference when he was
describing how cicadas dagger worked
coming back to him
it's like Mjolnir like Thor's hammer but
you also get the human side of what he's
doing so like I said during my last big
trailer video he's meant to be a
blue-collar villain unlike zoom or the
reverse-flash who have these grand
world-changing designs he just wants to
get rid of metas because they're bad
they cause problems they hurt people
like the daughter that he lost they sort
of paid that off a little bit at the end
of the episode - when he almost killed
Barry but for Nora screaming out dad for
him this is also a way of letting you
know that they're gonna do scenes with
cicada where he's not wearing his
costume we'll actually see like him
walking around in broad daylight doing
whatever his day job is Nora tells
everyone else on team flash what's going
on with the future newspaper so
everybody's on the same page there
aren't any big secrets that seems like a
big change from previous seasons the
meta this week Vanessa Jansen isn't
somebody that I could find in the comics
so I don't know if there are any
references to her but the Moretti's are
actually from the comics there's a carla
Moretti that's a Titans character that
has powers of pyrokinesis so they're
just pulling from all over the place but
they sort of explained the way her
powers work during the episode she
shoots compressed air molecules that
trap people that speedsters can't
vibrate their way through but number 9
we have that funny scene with Nora
trying to be the CSI intern make it
official when you get back this is their
way of letting you know that they're
going to continue to have Nora Barry CSI
scenes at the police station and add-on
cases for the rest of the season however
long noir is gonna be here I'll probably
talk about the different season arcs
during the trailer video that I do for
episode 3 because it's a little bit
separate from this but the show is going
to be broken up into three different
arcs instead of doing one big arc so
cicada might not wind up being the
villain in the back half of the season
they have a couple funny moments about
Barry not having any of the cool CSI
tech that Nora has in the future she
keeps saying shui during the episode at
least twice one at the beginning during
this scene and then one at the end when
she was watching the footage of Barry
we'll have to start counting and see if
she says it in every single episode this
season they kind of set up that Cisco
break up arc but he moved past it pretty
quickly so he's transitioning back to
life as regular Cisco who's not moping
around being weird all the time
but number 8 this is actually pretty
cool Nora lets us know not everything
about the Flash's history is inside the
flash Museum you were in prison that
wasn't in the flash Museum because the
museum isn't just about having all the
good stuff that happened to the flash it
has bad stuff in there too that he did
but I think the reason why is is because
it was Barry Allen that was sent to
prison not the flash and even in the
future his secret identity is still a
big thing so if they were to include
that in the museum in the future it
would out his secret identity and it
would be a big problem for Nora because
she wants to be the flash of the future
number 7 Nora and Barry team up to take
down the new meta and Moretti but she
derps gets thrown halfway across the
city just like Barry did during the
first episode so it was nice parallel
for that scene a little bit funny a
little bit frustrating so number 6 he
takes her to speedster school my flash
hero academia they have more funny
back-and-forth about how things are
different in the future dad all this
info is in my grade school textbooks
I know physics that you guys haven't
even thought of yet you have that funny
moment with her hitting him with
lightning accidentally it's okay I've
been hit with lightning before I think
that Barry including this time has been
hit with lightning at least five times
number one was in the pilot season two
was when Jay Garrick was teaching him to
throw lightning three when zoom hit him
with his own bolt of lightning then
later during season two when he tried to
go back into the Speed Force the first
time he had to get hit with lightning
again then this one being the fifth time
I may be forgetting one but he gets hit
by lightning on a
pretty frequent basis so not that big of
a deal while this is all going on they
have that running Cisco plotline with
them trying to freshen him up give him a
new look I think they just meant to be
his new style for the season like they
give him some new clothes a bit of a
haircut everybody gets a bit of a
costume change season to season so I
think this is his version of doing that
but while this is all going on and they
go through that funny breakup book
Caitlin actually loses her temper and it
seems like it's just foreshadowing for a
killer frost stuff happening down the
road because she still doesn't know how
to bring her out but usually it has
something to do with extreme emotional
states number 5 Cisco helps Caitlin get
over her fear of finding her father what
if he doesn't want me what if he was
alive this whole time and didn't want to
see me the interesting thing about that
is that we see when Cisco finally vibes
the death certificate we see her mother
getting someone else to do it remember
the person that signed it man ket is
actually the original version of icicle
from the comics so this is them
foreshadowing an icicle story for her
father but I couldn't see the face over
that shoulder there so it's either her
father signing his own death certificate
or it's her mother getting some other
scientists to do it I think he's
actually supposed to show up sometime in
the next couple of episodes so once we
see him we'll talk a little bit more
about that but number 4 Nora is able to
take down block the second time after
she almost gets buried by just having
her burn too much energy she gets really
tired so it's a big win for Nora but
then just as they're about to walk away
with Cisco cicada gets her takes her
down and it's number three team flash
vs. cicada
who hands them their asses just because
they don't understand how his powers
work and he's able to leech all of their
abilities temporarily while he beats
them to a pulp so if you guys didn't
catch it when he was taking gridlocks
powers what happens is is the dagger
leeches ability is temporarily once he
stabs them after the fact
that's when it soaks up the rest of
their powers and makes it permanent so
everyone that was standing near the
dagger lost their abilities Barry has to
fight him he's a lightweight so he gets
his ass beat because cicada is huge
cicada goes in for the kill to take the
rest of his powers just as Nora screams
out dad that's what makes him pause and
leave Barry so the whole idea is is that
trying to show you that he's not a total
psycho and he's doing all
killing all these metas because his
daughter died so in that way I think
that they're trying to write him a
little bit better than they wrote say
like the zoom character who didn't have
quite as strong a motivation why do you
want to destroy the multiverse after
trying to take everyone's speed because
I had a terrible childhood not the
greatest motivation in the world so you
guys can let me know what you think of
them doing with cicadas so far but the
big WTF at the end of the episode number
one is Nora realizing who the villain is
because she's been to the flash Museum
so she's read all about cicada the look
on her face should tell you everything
about what's to come like oh this is
gonna be bad
if you're not a big comic book reader
mythologically cicadas also represent
immortality I don't know how many of the
comic book cicada powers are gonna give
to TV show cicada but they've already
changed a couple of things so as we get
more footage like next week it's gonna
be team flash for cicada again we'll
talk more about comic book Easter eggs
now we have to talk about the crossover
promo the whole idea here I think is
that it's supposed to be our version of
Earth one Oliver and that's why they
took the chin out of the flash costume
this season so that you would see
Oliver's beard during the crossover that
is crazy then tuning a costume just for
this big crossover so after this is all
done they'll probably give Barry his
chin back and people can stop
complaining about that because it does
look kind of weird without the chin we
also got pictures of them behind the
scenes dressed up as the trigger twins
from the comics so either we're gonna
see a bunch of different universe
versions of the characters or it's just
gonna be our versions of the characters
and someone is going to be supremely
messing with the timeline in the
multiverse but because it's called
Elseworlds and it sounds like a
multiverse whole story
we'll see how crazy they get with that I
actually tweeted about this earlier this
year because in the comics they were
drawing Barry Allen and he looked very
similar to real-life Stephen Amell so
what a great joke but Stephen has also
been in Green Arrow costume during
crossover behind the scenes so they're
gonna be doing a whole bunch of
different versions of the characters
will get more promos for that later this
year what will happen is is I'll do a
flash trailer tomorrow morning there's a
whole bunch more spider-man and Marvel
stuff happening too so post all your
theories in the comments below I'll name
a giveaway winner when I post
that trailer video click here to watch
Tom Hiddleston talk about Loki and learn
about when the Avengers four trailer is
going to drop and click here for my
flash episode 1 video thank you so much
for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]